[Music]
the movie starts in the year 2014 global
warming is at its height and climate
change is about to end human life once
and for all the common people are
relying on scientists to somehow save
the world while even the scientists are
panicking at the rate of decreasing
resources when humanity is only a step
away from extinction a magical coolant
called cw7 is discovered with the
correct amount of cw-7 in the atmosphere
the world is said to go back to its
natural form without wasting any time
the authorities in 79 countries
collectively decide to release a certain
amount of cw7 into the atmosphere the
program is initiated and completed
successfully however the results are
something that no one could have
imagined in their wildest dreams instead
of battling global warming cw7 cools the
atmosphere to extreme levels so much so
that the entire world freezes and the
earth goes back to the ice age almost
all human beings freeze to death in less
than a week only a tiny percentage of
humans survive by getting on a train
called snow piercer built by a railway
specialist wilford it is powered by a
perpetual motion engine that is able to
work even in extreme temperatures the
train never stops moving all 24 hours of
365 days this is because the heating
system inside only works when it
continuously moves or else even the
train would freeze the railway track
goes to different countries as it is
created by joining every track in the
world together the train takes exactly a
year to make a full circle of its track
which is how people measure time now 17
years later in 2031 the train is still
in motion and has never come to a halt
inside people are divided into three
different classes the leader of the
entire human population is the creator
of the train wilford it is said that he
lives above the engine storage and has
an entire room to himself wilfred is
ballin after him are the elites who only
make up to one percentage of the
population they live in the frontal
compartments and get to enjoy all the
luxuries in life like bars expensive
restaurants saloons hospitals and even
schools for their children today kids
we're gonna teach you how [ __ ] you are
second comes the middle compartment
which consists of laborers who work for
the first class people they do not
receive as many services but get the
opportunity to work their way up to the
first class then in the last window tiny
compartment lives a population of
freeloaders who are treated like cattle
they are not given any resources other
than occasional black bars of gluten the
group survives by reminding themselves
at least they are alive but they don't
even have the privilege to look at the
sunlight for food the train has a
built-in greenhouse that grows enough
vegetables for the first and second
classes meanwhile water is created by
melting ice in front of the train one
afternoon two guards go to the last
compartment to distribute food it is
again the jelly-like substance called
the protein bar this time the guards
inquire if there is a violinist on board
since they need one for the
entertainment of the first class people
an old couple comes forward but it turns
out that only one can come with them
when the couple refuses to go without
each other the guards push the old woman
and drag her husband away the leaders of
the freeloaders are two young men named
curtis and edgar they do as much as they
can for the community but haven't been
able to make any significant change
every day they receive a single capsule
with a message inside one random protein
bar the messages range from the
blueprint of the train to motivating
quotes this time the capsule contains
the name of the designer of the train
nom he is currently held as a prisoner
in the prison compartment no one knows
who sends the capsule messages but
curtis believes that they are an ally in
the past 17 years freeloaders have
protested twice they failed both times
and caused many deaths but their spirit
to fight for equal rights hasn't changed
curtis and edgar are constantly planning
their next move and encouraging people
to join them one of the passengers among
the freeloaders is an old man named
gilliam he is missing one arm and a leg
but is determined to improve their
living situation he is also the
spiritual leader of the group and is the
one holding everyone together curtis
comes to gilliam to show him the latest
message they believe that someone wants
curtis to meet designer nom as they talk
the guards enter the compartment and
start measuring the height of every kid
at last they decide to take two kids
named timmy and andy timmy's mother begs
and cries for them to stop but the
guards push her away a man named andrew
throws his shoe at the guards making
their blood boil then we are introduced
to a woman named minister mason she is
in charge of maintaining peace and
security on the train and is also the
only first class person the freeloaders
have ever seen as punishment mason makes
andrew keep his hand out of the train
for seven minutes when he brings the arm
inside it is completely frozen the
guards then cut it with a hammer leaving
him bleeding and in pain mason tells the
freeloaders to let this be a lesson
because they are like shoes whose very
job is to stay at the bottom after
everything calms down the entire
freeloader community fumes in anger this
is not the first time they have been
treated like animals but this time they
have had enough of the injustice that
entire night they make an elaborate plan
to attack the guards rumor has it that
the guards ran out of bullets in the
last protest and are carrying empty guns
curtis takes it upon himself to see if
the rumor is true the next day the
compartment door opens and then comes a
guy who brings food daily curtis walks
to him and points the gun at himself
asking the man to shoot lo and behold
the gun turns out to be empty which is a
sign for the others to attack the plan
works and they managed to enter the
prison section of the train there curtis
meets designer nom whose name was
written on the last message nam and his
little daughter yona are addicted to a
substance called chronol they only agree
to join the group if they are provided
with enough chronol curtis agrees and
welcomes them to the freeloader
community using his skills nom opens the
door to the next compartment which has a
window the group can almost not believe
how bright the compartment is as they
finally get to see sunlight after 17
years following that they enter the
kitchen area specially made for the poor
class to their horror they discover that
the protein bar they've been feeding on
is made up of ground cockroaches after a
few more compartments they will reach
the water filtrate gilliam advises that
they hold the filtrate in their
possession which gives them a ground for
negotiation with the guards that way
they can ask for equal rights in turn
for water however they are met with a
surprise when they open the next door
and see a horde of guards with axes
waiting for them a fight ensues where
many people from both sides lose their
lives amidst the battle nam sees a point
outside the train which he clearly
remembers was not visible last year when
he wasn't in prison this means that the
ice outside is surely melting to some
extent and humankind will soon be able
to live on the ground suddenly mason
makes an announcement and asks the
guards to kill 70 of the freeloaders at
the same time they cross through a
tunnel which gives the guards an upper
hand because they own night vision
goggles many of curtis's people die in
the following fight but in the end the
cruel minister is captured and
threatened so she orders the guards to
stop the freeloaders want to kill the
woman but they still need her to
manipulate the guards upon being asked
she reveals that the children that were
stolen yesterday are with the captain of
the train wilford she doesn't know what
he does with children but is aware that
he orders many of them mason promises to
bring the group to wilford's compartment
in exchange for her life curtis agrees
but only a handful of people led by him
decide to join mason the rest stay
behind for their own safety before
leaving andrew makes a portrait of the
group alongside mason who has a shoe on
her head it is a slap back for the time
she compared the freeloaders to shoes
who are supposed to be on the bottom
following that they make their way to
the first class lounges that consist of
an aquarium a greenhouse with fresh
fruits and a sushi station mason asks
them to sit down for sushi and
shamelessly boasts about the services
but while the others enjoy fresh fish
she is made to eat the protein bar the
next compartment is the school for
children starting from an early age they
are brainwashed about freeloaders and
are taught to look up to wilford as
their king timmy's mother asks them
about the missing kids and a little boy
reveals that they were taken through the
front door at the same time the train
passes a monumental place it is the area
where the bodies of seven frozen people
are clearly visible they were explorers
who jumped off the train a few years ago
hoping to survive on land back in the
compartment of the freeloaders everyone
is impatiently waiting for the group to
return with good news surprisingly they
are approached by a man with a cart full
of eggs they are shocked because they
were under the impression that all forms
of animals on earth are dead the man
laughs claiming that it is just a rumor
just like the story about empty guns is
also a rumor with that being said he
brings out a gun and starts firing at
them similarly the teacher in the
children's classroom also does the same
she manages to kill andrew before curtis
kills her the classroom also has a
monitor where the cctv footage of the
last compartment is shown a guard in the
compartment brings gilliam in front of
the camera and shoots him dead gilliam
was very close to curtis's heart hence
the death crushes his spirit in anger
and to take revenge he shoots mason dead
then the surviving group moves forward
and ends up in a room filled with
high-class people socializing with each
other they are enjoying luxuries like
alcohol expensive clothes saloons
medicines and doctors right before the
group enters the engine room another
batch of guards attacks them they fight
with all they have but timmy's mother
dies in the battle now the only
surviving ones are curtis nom and his
daughter yonah they cross a club filled
with high youngsters and finally reach
the door to wilford's room opening the
door is out of nom's expertise so they
sit down for a while curtis starts
telling the story of the time when they
were new to the train for the first few
months the lowest class were provided
with no food whatsoever when desperation
hit they resorted to cannibalism the
older people liked to eat children
because their meat was tender and curtis
also took part in it one day he was so
hungry that he wanted to eat edgar
curtis's late partner who was just a kid
back then at that time gilliam stopped
him and offered his hand in exchange for
the kid's life that is how he lost one
arm and a leg some days later they were
miraculously given the protein bars and
the population survived however the
guilt of what curtis did never left his
mind ever since this is why he is so
adamant about fighting for his people
after listening to the story nom reveals
that life outside the train is possible
and tells curtis about the mountain that
is visible now he also discloses that he
is not an addict and has been collecting
chronol to make an explosive he wants to
use it to make a hole in the train and
go outside just when he is about to
light it on fire wilfred's assistant
shoots him in the leg and brings curtis
inside in the following scene he finally
gets to meet wilford who has grown old
wilford reveals that he was the one who
sent those messages in the capsules and
he did so to start a riot every few
years he stirs up the lower class so
they protest and a few people are killed
this is a drastic measure taken to
ensure the population on board remains
manageable the protesters were supposed
to be killed when the tunnel arrived but
mason being abducted changed everything
not just that but gilliam also knew
about the plan and was helping wilford
from the inside even though he did so to
keep the human population alive curtis
cannot help but be disappointed in him
outside nom and yona are still trying to
set off the explosive when the first
class maniacs attack nom jonah panics
and runs to curtis to ask for help they
suddenly notice a compartment on the
floor where portimi is sitting in
between the engines and working because
the space is tiny only kids can repair
the broken parts but instead of the
first class children wilfred chose the
poor ones this is the last straw for
curtis he attacks wilfred and knocks him
out before trying to help teemi out of
the compartment outside jonah lights the
explosive on fire everything goes silent
for a few seconds before a loud bang
lights the entire train on fire it
derails and everyone inside dies from
the impact in the final scene we see
yonah and timi walk out of the wreckage
as the sole survivors of the crash they
notice a polar bear nearby meaning that
life on earth has returned and they have
a chance to survive but let's be honest
they're dead for sure
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching